[Musique]
oui
pour pallier au manque de commerces et
de restauration sur le campus urbain on
a décidé de mettre en place une flotte
de foutraque sur l'ensemble du campus en
partenariat avec les communes et la
communauté d'agglomération
pour cela on va lancer un appel à
projets afin de trouver les bons fous
treuil pour s'installer sur les
différents sites
donc on a lancé ça à l'automne et on a
obtenu une quarantaine de réponse sur
lesquels on a choisi une vente de food
truck finalement qui ont été lauréates
cet appel à projet cfoot vient de
rejoindre ceux qui sont déjà présents
sur le campus du côté d' or c est sur le
quartier camille claudel à palaiseau qui
étaient présents plusieurs années ça
vient densifier l'offre de restauration
parmi ces 22 foutraque on a une offre
diversifiée de restauration du couvre
finalement à la fois des prix différents
pour les étudiants pour les salariés
pour les chercheurs mais aussi des
produits différents des catégories
différentes avec à la fois des
classiques de la pizzeria du burger mais
aussi des produits végétariens des repas
diversifiée on retrouve sur le campus
plusieurs emplacements
ici on est sur l'un des emplacements le
carré des sciences sur le gif sur yvette
un autre emplacement sur or c est deux
emplacements sur palaiseau l'idée étant
d'offrir
une offre commerciale et de restauration
aux étudiants et aux salariés aux
différents moments de la journée
puisqu'il y aura des coups très présents
le matin aux horaires du petit déjeuner
pour les gens qui souhaitent prendre un
café en descendant du bus par exemple le
midi pour la restauration va dire plus
classique sur la pause déjeuner et le
soir ici principalement à côté des
résidences étudiantes pour satisfaire
les besoins des de cette population
l'opération vient d'être lancée donc les
poutres hug sont opérationnels depuis
février 2018 pour une période de six
mois en phase test et ont vocation à
être prolongée si ça fonctionne et si ça
on compte son public
[Musique]